el presidente de Alberto Fernández
comenzó pidiendo un aplauso
especialmente para la reincorporación de
Brasil a este foro regional algo que él
considera muy importante y por supuesto
tiene peso por el tamaño de Brasil y su
importancia en la región también hizo
muy al inicio una referencia al Caribe
dijo que el Caribe tiene problemas
específicos como la problemática muy muy
marcada vinculada con el cambio
climático Tal vez un guiño a San Vicente
y Las Granadinas esa pequeña nación
caribeña que está postulándose como para
seguir para seguir como la próxima
presidenta protén por el mercosur perdón
de la celac digo mercosur porque este
vínculo de mercosur con la cera que es
muy fuerte por esta presencia tan fuerte
de Brasil y también de Argentina y por
supuesto también es una referencia a la
importancia de la defensa de la
democracia en la región hizo un
señalamiento que viene apareciendo muy
constantemente en estos días que esa a
la derecha regional que está
posicionando se cada vez más fuerte una
suerte de extrema derecha regional que
él dice que representa un peligro para
la institucionalidad